[Music]
i grew up being a self-centered kid in
school
sure i could do fast math
but i did not give a [ __ ] about others
who could not
i could calculate the cube root of 738
in my head when i was just 12.
but when my friends
struggling with basic fractions and
decimals asked me for help i turned a
blind eye
i hadn't mastered calculus yet
the national math olympiad was around
the corner
and my parents and teachers had big
expectations of me
i needed to focus on myself
and my friends would have done the same
thing if they were in my place
i received straight a's in the math and
sciences
but if there had been a class for
helping people
i would have got an f
the national education system in india
like in many parts of the world is
predicated on the idea of relative
performance and competition
and this dominates our view of success
i didn't think it was possible to break
out of this belief
until i met two people four years back
anju and zabi
two kids nearly half my age
anju just 15 years old lived in a
village that did not send girls to
school
but rather than try to move to a
different village and get her education
she devoted her energy in changing the
minds of people in her community
her determination changed the system
and she has now had more than 200 girls
to enroll in school and become educated
zabi just 16
convinced his school principal to start
an animal shelter in the school campus
where he and his fellow classmates have
rescued more than 300 injured dogs to
date
i was
fascinated with anju and zabi
for the first time in my life i met
teenagers who cared deeply about others
and took action to make things better
i certainly wasn't like them when i was
in school
and neither were the kids i knew
so why was that
why were anju and zabi the outliers and
not the mainstream
the more i thought about it it all
pointed to our education systems and the
extreme competitive pressure that is put
on kids
you got good grades
great now get better grades
you made it into a good college fine now
get into a better college
life
becomes this competitive race
and this race and girls children in an
inward looking me focus mindset
rather than developing an outward
looking we focus mindset
children leave schools with impressive
grades and certificates and get decent
jobs
but they miss becoming empathetic
responsible conscious citizens of this
world
but should school systems choose
between academic accidents
and empathy and compassion
i didn't think so and i chose to do
something about it
i quit my job and started a social
enterprise to try and tackle this issue
as part of our research i read a lot
about people who have dedicated their
lives towards the betterment of society
and how they developed their passion for
it
that's when i was introduced to bill
drayton
bill is credited by many for coining the
term social entrepreneur back in the
1970s
ashoka the non-profit he founded
supports social entrepreneurs in more
than 40 countries today
but what's interesting is this when bill
was 11
he had started an initiative to help his
classmates by creating a class newspaper
he skipped a lot of classes because of
his strong commitment and wasn't even
home most evenings
when bill's mother died he found
correspondence between her and her
school principal his mother was
concerned she asked why is a fifth
grader not in your school or our home
the school principal wrote back saying
trust your son
and please don't show your anxious
bill was unaware of this at the time but
when he thinks back on it he says
bless that principle who encouraged my
ability to make an impact in this world
we found two patterns in the stories of
people like bill
number one
most developed their passion for
creating change by going through an
outward-centric change-making experience
at a very young age
and number two they had at least one
adult who believed and supported them in
their journey
inspired by these earnings our team
designed a program for middle school and
high school children
our idea was to encourage the kids to
identify social or environmental issues
in their home school or community
support them as it took action to try
and tackle these issues
and appreciate them for their efforts
our role as facilitators was to do three
simple things encourage support and
appreciate
or what we called the esa framework in
short
who could be against such a program
right
yet we couldn't convince a single school
in the first two months
schools rejected us outright saying that
they did not see any value and that
children needed to focus solely on their
academics
we finally offered the entire program to
schools for free for an entire year to
get them to try it out
not an ideal start for us but we took
what we could get
if convincing schools and parents was
tricky
thankfully working with children was the
exact opposite
children loved our program
they quickly identified the problems
they wanted to tackle and passionately
got to work
chandan just 11 years old told us
i want everyone in my school to be
physically fit
his school did not offer a physical
fitness program so he gathered a group
of other sixth graders and started a
student-run yoga class for everyone
even two years since our program ended
the children still run their yoga class
and in fact have expanded their
initiative to five nearby schools
incredible
chandan's teacher recently told us that
chandan was an extremely shy kid at
first
but once he got a platform to solve a
problem he cared about
he discovered a new side of himself
chandan is no longer that timid child
he's an empowered agent of change
kirti just 15 started the code red
initiative to spread awareness about
menstrual hygiene in underprivileged
communities near her school
she was so successful that now three
years since her program she is helping
an ngo create awareness about celebrity
policy
dvd vicente told me
in my 10 years of schooling i never had
an adult who encouraged me to think
about helping my community but as soon
as i received that encouragement
my life changed and now i want to
continue tackling meaningful issues for
the rest of my life
this was common amongst all the students
after working with more than 25 000
children over three years
our biggest realization was this
all children are born with empathy and
compassion
the challenge is to remain with it as we
grow up
these humane values can either thrive
and flourish with encouragement and
support from adults
or
they can be completely stifled and
suppressed
which is what happens through our
education systems
which one do we all want for our
children
for our community
we have big problems today
political polarization
growing in inequality
climate change
we must fundamentally change the way we
are raising our children
we must set them free from this inward
looking me focused mindset to an outward
looking refocus mindset
looking back i don't believe my career
would have been any less successful if i
had more empathy and compassion as a
child
but i can't help but wonder how much
better the lives of my other young
friends would have been
would their careers be better
would they have passed along the empathy
they had experienced onto their own
children
academicians researchers and advocates
are fighting to include empathy and
compassion into the formal curriculum at
the institutional level
and each one of us you and me can make a
difference at the individual level
implement esa
encourage the children in your life to
think about and help others
support them when they start something
meaningful
and appreciate them for when they put in
the efforts
be their champion the one who keeps
their empathy alive so that no matter
who they become professionally or where
they go in the future
they create a better world for everyone
thank you very much
[Music]
you